the show obviously is so much fun and um
i feel like for you steven it's probably
like a dream sort of realized you're
such a big pro wrestling fan
tell me what it's like to be part of the
show i know you have some experience but
yeah i mean i was joking without joking
with alexander and i'll say it again but
this
you know this this uh this experience
merged my two favorite things in life
which are
uh
disorder professional wrestling and
seeing myself on tv
i love that um
sorry so go ahead go ahead no no you
continue continue
i'm saying that an all-star in all
seriousness this is um this is a dream
job it's a dream come true uh if film
and television and professional
wrestling are outside of outside of
sports they're probably the two things
that i'm most passionate about in terms
of following and in terms of things that
are creatively stimulating to me
and and so these two worlds to
these two worlds to come together um god
it's just it's really special it's
really special that's awesome um
alexander how about for you how familiar
were you with pro wrestling before doing
this project
i was that kid in vancouver who would
like turn on his tv and when wwe was on
i'd watch it and i loved it but i
wouldn't say i followed it religiously i
throughout the course of my career i've
been able to work with some monster
heels like dwayne johnson and adam edge
copeland and i leaned heavily on adam
when i was preparing for this um
so i've learned i've grown to love it
and respect it tremendously i mean the
amount
of uh athleticism that goes in to this
sport is incredible um i mean these
people use and abuse their bodies on a
regular basis
i'm telling you when you hit those ropes
and and take your first bump on the mat
um and your bell gets wrong it's it's no
joke um
and you know it was really important
stephen and i that we did right by the
wrestling community i mean this is a
show for everyone everyone can see
themselves in these characters and it's
a tremendously well-written show but we
wanted the wrestling community when they
saw this to know that we put in the work
i well that's my next question was what
was the training for this show like i
don't know if you just want to
start off on that yeah i mean when we
signed on to the show immediately we
were in a gym with shadow guerrero for
for months before he comes from a very
prolific wrestling family uh for months
before we even set foot on a film set
then we moved to atlanta the gym was
built for us uh when we weren't in the
gym we were in the wrestling ring and it
was
our stunt team was comprised of uh pro
and amateur wrestlers uh who are
incredible shout out to luke hawks um
who who trained us
and when we weren't filming we were in
the gym and in the ring and it was just
this constant circle for eight months
during cobit it was crazy
um stephen i don't know i'll ask this to
you first were there any pro wrestlers
that you took inspiration from i know
obviously these are original characters
but was there anyone in particular that
you sort of harnessed when you were took
on this role uh yeah i mean i don't know
if he knows this but i love watching
kevin owens work
um
you know
no one can
i don't know if there's anyone on the
mic on the stick in in in the business
right now they can insult a crowd and
and make people feel stupid the way that
kevin owens came
and and that's that's that's a lot of
what i wanted from jack spade you know i
wanted him to be i wanted him to be a
really good worker
but i wanted i wanted him i wanted
people to
i wanted people to believe
that
that he that he just had utter disdain
for his paying customers
you know which is the fun part about
being a heel and um yes a little kevin
owens and there's a
there's a rick
there's a semi-rick flair
uh face plant thrown into episode three
shout out to rick love that guy
that's you um and before i let you go
alex anybody that you took inspiration
from
i mean there's certainly i would say i
take tidbits from different things i'd
seen when i was doing my research but
you're definitely going to see a sean
michael super kick in there
you